depuis des milliers d'années elle nous
effraie et nous fascine
les astronomes dante depuis toujours de
percer leur mystère
elles ont engendré peur et légendes
les comètes ses visiteurs céleste ne
nous offre aucune représentation unique
les comètes sont les nomades de notre
système solaire
certaines voyage selon des orbites
elliptiques au milieu des planètes
des comètes kamikazes se jettent
directement dans le soleil d'autres
frôlent sa surface brûlante et
disparaissent pour toujours
l'histoire des comètes remonte à la nuit
des temps pour comprendre d'où elles
viennent
et pourquoi elles sont importantes il
nous faut remonter dans le passé
voyager 5 milliards d'années en arrière
jusqu'à la naissance de notre système
solaire dans une nébuleuse primitive les
éléments les plus lourds se sont
combinés pour former le soleil et les
planètes interne des petits mondes
solide comme la terre et mars
en devenant plus chaud le soleil
produisit un vent solaire qui
transportait des éléments plus léger
ces éléments allaient former les
planètes externe des géantes gazeuses
comme jupiter élèves d'une au delà de
ces planètes à un tiers du chemin vers
l'étoile la plus proche
le vent solaire a déposé une coquille de
poussière et de glace le nuage de oort
c'est de ce nuage que tombent les
comètes
peut-être sous l'influencé des douanes
voisine une comète quitte le nuage de
hordes et tombe vers le soleil le noyau
d'une comète est formé d'un amas de
glace salle sa taille peut aller d'un
stade de football à une ville toute
entière inchangé par le temps où la
température le coeur est une relique de
notre système solaire tel qu'il l'était
au commencement
en s'approchant du soleil la glace
commence à se transformer en vapeur
créant une queue de gaz fluorés sens en
passant là que essoufflé en arrière par
le vent solaire
c'est ainsi que débute l'odyssée de
plusieurs milliards de kilomètres d'une
comète
la queue d'une comète peut s'étendre sur
plus de 160 millions de kilomètres de
long dans l'espace
pourtant elle n'existe que dans la
chaleur des planètes interne quand la
comète revient dans les profondeurs
externe froide ça que disparaît
vu de la terre une comète veut briller
dans le ciel pendant plusieurs semaines
voici la comète ikeya c'est qu'ils
observaient en 1965 et la comète ouest
en 1976 bien qu'elle se déplace à une
vitesse de plusieurs kilomètres par
seconde
elle semble suspendu immobile dans le
ciel belle et sereine les comètes semble
bien éloigné de notre vie quotidienne
pourtant dans le passé des comètes sont
entrés en collision avec la terre et ce
phénomène peut se reproduire
en 1994 la cible était jupiter
mais le soleil reste la cible la plus
fréquente
ici en accéléré une comète frôlé sa
surface est ici d'autres plongent dans
son coeur brûlant
les étoiles filantes suivent de près les
comètes les comètes polluent le monde à
l'échelle cosmique en laissant derrière
elle des traînées de poussière en
pénétrant dans notre atmosphère à plus
de 64 kilomètres par seconde
la poussière s'enflamme à cause de la
friction et même des grains de poussière
minuscule peuvent illuminer la nuit
comme des météorites de plus grand des
bris de l'espace produisent des boules
de feu spectaculaire si elles sont assez
grandes ailes survivrons et deviendrons
des météorites qui heurteront la surface
de la terre par hasard un homme armé
d'une caméra vidéo a filmé cette boule
de feu explosant au dessus de pittsburgh
en 1992
le rocher peut être le plus célèbre de
l'espace est aujourd'hui certiid argent
est placé à la base d'une structure noir
la kaaba
dans la ville sainte de la mecque c'est
le hajj le pèlerinage des millions de
fidèles se rassemblent dans cette ville
berceau du prophète mahomet
comme les musulmans dans le monde entier
les pèlerins se tourner vers leurs
pierres sacrées pour prier il pense que
c'est un présent de l'archange gabriel à
abraham
mais cette pierre à une autre histoire -
sacré certains savants pense qu'il
s'agit d'une météorite un des
innombrables missiles qui ont frappé la
surface de la terre depuis que notre
planète existe
l'australie une terre de contrastes
au delà de la zone urbaine s'aidant d'un
immense continent grâce à son climat
aride et son paysage vierge l'intérieur
de l'australie est un terrain de
prédilection pour les hommes qui
cherchent des traces de collision
cosmique
ici les points d'impact ont subi aucune
altération dû au climat ou aux hommes
voici les cratères de hand burry creusée
par des météorites
le cratère de wolf creek est aussi le
résultat d'un impact de l'espace
il mesure plus de 800 mètres de diamètre
agos bluff voici la preuve d'un autre
impact large de 14 km ce cratère est
vieux de 20 millions d'années et en
sibérie au début du siècle
une énorme explosion au ciel a détruit
une forêt c'est la preuve que l'espace
ne menace sans cesse
le mont palomar en californie une
découverte extraordinaire eu lieu à
travers son télescope
en 1993 trois astronomes eugène et
caroline schneider et david levy
découvrir une nouvelle est étrange comme
m c'est nous qui avons découvert cette
comète ainsi qu'un jeune français
philippe bendjo ian hacking pic en
arizona où le télescope fouille le ciel
à la recherche des visiteurs stellaire
l'observation de schumaker et vie fut
confirmée ce n'était pas une comète
ordinaire la comète de chômeurs lévis
était un filet de lumière en orbite
autour du soleil
une comète avec de multiples noyau
les astronomes du monde entier se tenait
prêt dans les andes au chili à
l'observatoire européen du sud
des observateurs enregistrèrent des
images de la nouvelle comète
ce qu'ils virent n'était pas une comète
unique mais un escadron entier de
comètes volant en formation
chacune prennent en une queue de
poussière
des images prises par le télescope
spatial hubble révèle à un rang de
perles formé en 1992 quand la comète
s'approcha un peu trop près de jupiter
son immense force de gravitation avait
déchiré la comète en 1994
ces montages de débris allait s'écraser
sur jupiter à 200 mille kilomètres heure
artiste des savants imaginaire ce qui
allait se passer
pour la première fois dans l'histoire du
monde nous pourrions observer une comète
s'écraser sur une autre planète jupiter
la géante gazeuse 1300 voix plus grosse
que la terre
pourtant les impacts aurait lieu sur la
face cachée de jupiter hors de vue de la
terre les observateurs devraient
attendre que la rotation de la planète
dévoile un par un les impacts
et que verrait-il dépannage de gaz
s'échapperait peut-être des profondeurs
de jupiter
des superordinateurs dessinèrent des
prévisions détaillées des détonations
égal à plusieurs millions de mégatonnes
de tnt
des vagues de nuages avançant civic qui
traverserait le pacifique en quelques
minutes
jupiter semblait frissonner
d'anticipation du moins électroniquement
juillet 1994 en nouvelle galles du sud
le télescope australien s'orienter vers
sa cible la semaine de la comète allait
commencer et shoemaker levy joué son
rôle à la perfection mieux que les
astronomes ne l'avaient espéré
jour après jour tandis que les fragments
de comètes s'écraser sur jupiter leur
point d'impact devenait visible des
images dégageant de la chaleur
enregistrèrent plus de vingt collision
majeure
certaines plus importante que prévu
en australie les astronomes attendu une
apothéose
le rêve de tout astronome une vision
parfaite des premiers impacts de céleste
jamais prévu
on
les impacts étaient puissants et rapides
chaque fragment de comètes fut baptisé
d'une lettre ce soir les astronomes
surveille l'impact du fragment w david
crips du laboratoire jpl en californie
dirige cette équipe
plus le fragment w s'approcher de
jupiter plus la tension monte la comète
allait-elle s'écraser avec un bang ou
avec un soupir elle fut éblouissante un
signal si brillant que les astronomes
dur protégé les détecteurs sensible des
télescopes
bon
et maintenant la photo de l'explosion ce
soir là l'équipe de cliffs avait fait la
plus belle image prises depuis la terre
à l'autre bout du monde aux états unis
les découvreurs de la comète devenaient
des stars de l'astronomie
je crois que nous avons le grand
privilège ce soir de voir un événement
qui non seulement unique dans une vie
mais même dans un siècle c'est comme si
la nature vous appelé au téléphone pour
vous dire je vais lâcher 20 commettre
sur jupiter à 220 km heure je vous
demande seulement de regarder c'est une
expérience qui s'arrose chantal le rang
de perles de chômer coeur et vit un mois
avant l'impact
le fragment w la précision avec laquelle
les astronomes ont prédit les impacts
fut extraordinaire dans l'infrarouge
les impacts sont visibles comme les yeux
d'un chat mais il y eut peu de photos
comme cette séquence prises depuis le
vaisseau spatial galileo ici le fragment
w s'écrase sur la face sombre de jupiter
hawaï l'immense télescope keck capture à
l'explosion quand elle fut visible
depuis la terre
un champignon nuageux de 960 km de haut
selva au dessus de l'horizon de jupiter
depuis son perchoir en orbite autour de
la terre le télescope spatial hubble
avait photographié le phénomène sans
interruption pendant 12 heures à bâle
réalisa ce magnifique portrait des
fragments de chômer car des vies se
précipitant vers jupiter un bal pris
également cette photo la face meurtri de
jupiter trouée d'une demi douzaine de
coups
sur terre des collisions semblable
aurait été catastrophique ce croissant
noir sur cette photo représente une onde
de choc aussi grande que la terre elle
même
les savants avait pu prédire la
trajectoire de la comète shoemaker levy
il existe une autre comme est tout aussi
prévisible et nos jeunes spectateurs la
verront peut-être lors de son prochain
passage il y a longtemps une autre comet
a frôlé la surface de jupiter comme
shoemaker levy sont leurs beats était
sans cesse modifié par la gravité de la
planète géante
c'était la comète de halley
aujourd'hui elle voyage long d'une
orbite elliptique qu'il entraîne
au delà de neptune pour revenir faire un
tour autour du soleil
à cause de jupiter aller est prisonnière
d'un cycle de 76 ans sa dernière visite
à la terre était en 1986 et elle doit
revenir en 2061
nous avons commencé à comprendre les
comètes avec allez plus que tout autre
elle a permis de dévoiler le mystère de
leur origine l'histoire commence avec
l'astronome du xviie siècle
edmond aller
avant aller les savants pensait que les
comètes ne passer qu'une fois dans notre
ciel visiteurs fugaces qui ne revenaient
pas mais en 1608 un ami de allez y
automne observe a soigneusement le
mouvement d'une comète il calcula
qu'elle voyageait en orbite autour du
soleil
cette déduction faisait partie de sa
théorie de la gravitation
newton suggéra qu'une comète dans leurs
beats serait suffisamment petites pour
être vus plusieurs fois
non
afin de prouver cette théorie edmond
allait analyser le passage de 24 com est
il en déduisit deux importantes
conclusions d'abord trois de ces comètes
été séparés par le même intervalle de 26
ans
deuxièmement ces trois comète semblait
également avoir des orbites identique
s'agissait d'une seule comme est un
visiteur régulier dans ce cas sa
prochaine visite serait en 1758
et ce fut le cas le jour de noël en 1758
longtemps après la mort de haleh la
comète réapparu elle fut baptisée comète
de halley cette révélation permis aux
astronomes de remonter dans le passé de
cette comète
l'un des dessins de sept tombes chinoise
confirme le passage de aller au deuxième
siècle de notre ère une pièce frappée en
mémoire de jules césar porte également
l'image de aller qui avait été vue
pendant la jeunesse de l'empereur
voici ce que les gens appeler en 648 une
étoile palais c'est la même comète
en 1301 le peintre italien giotto fille
de la comète de halley l'étoile de
bethléem
allez n'étaient pas visibles lors de ce
premier noël mais certains astronomes
ont suggéré qu'une autre comme aide
avait guidé les rois mages
quant à l'airé apparu en 1910 le monde
de la publicité s'étaient emparés de la
comète la plus célèbre de notre histoire
les savants accueillir le retour de la
comète de halley avec un nouvel outil la
photographie mais les photos manquait de
détails
la comète gardait encore ses secrets
en 1985 la comète de halley est de
retour
cette fois ci les caméras d'une grande
sensibilité des télescopes géants et
toute une flotte de sonde l'attendait ce
fut les débuts de la comète de halley
sur la scène de l'espace et il y eut
profusion de photos ici une photo de
face montre des spirales de gaz
s'échappant dans l'espace
en 1986 les meilleures images furent
prises depuis l'hémisphère sud
ici o'shea après que aller et fait le
tour du soleil
et ici dans le ciel clair de l'afrique
équatoriale un nuage appelée la
chevelure est clairement visible autour
du noyau de la comète
dès que tordu de poussière qui semble
jaune quand on les observe à l'oeil nu
et une traînée rectiligne de gaz en bleu
fluorescent sur des millions de
kilomètres
une autre image prise d'afrique
pour la première fois les savants ne se
sont pas contentés d'observer la comète
ils sont allés à sa rencontre
une armada de vaisseaux spatiaux
robotisée s'envola à la rencontre de la
comète 2 soviétique deux japonaises et
une sonde européenne giotto giotto elle
est tenté de s'approcher du coeur même
de la comète
les savants voulait envoyer giotto au
coeur même de la chevelure est filmé
cette rencontre en vidéo
le tandis que joe tôt s'approcher de sa
proie les ordinateurs peignirent la
comète de fausses couleurs qui fournir
des informations inédites sur la
brillance et la densité de la commettre
mais les téléspectateurs furent déçus
par ces images
oui
dix-huit mois plus tard des
superordinateurs produisirent enfin
l'image que le public attendait et que
peu de gens avaient vu auparavant
au centre un noyau en forme de cacahuète
une boule de matières primitive de 9 km
sur 14
les geysers de gaz jaillissant à 20
tonnes par seconde et la poussière à 10
à travers la poussière
voilà le vrai visage de la comète de
halley
la transmission vidéo fut interrompue à
moins de 1500 kilomètres du but mais
giotto avait révélé une coquille sombre
et dur autour d'un coeur glacé
allez offrit à la terre son plus beau
spectacle tandis qu'elle s'éloignait du
soleil photographiée pendant plusieurs
mois
la queue de la comète allongée ou
raccourcissent et d'un jour à l'autre sa
brillance fluctue est également
les astronomes appris du rc variations
au vent solaire à des changements dans
la composition que sa surface et à la
rotation du noyau en passant du monde la
c29 d'une à la chaleur du soleil la
surface de aller avait atteint une
température de 90 degrés celsius
à la fin des années 80 allez commencer à
disparaître et son image avec elle
puis soudain en 1991 elle redevient
brillante la comète est elle entrée en
collision avec quelque chose nous le
saurons en 2061
en février 1994 la comète de halley
n'était plus qu'un point brillant sur
une photo elle venait de dépasser saturn
l'avenir apportera de nouvelles les
astronomes américains et européens
envisagent même l'idée de poser une
sonde sur une comète
aucun homme ne soit d'abord il ne
survivrait pas mais un robot muni de
nombreux capteurs fera leur travail
comme un médecin la sonde prendra la
température de la caunette et analysera
pour la première fois sa composition
chimique puis la sonde transmettra les
informations à la terre
les comètes des visiteurs gelé des
profondeurs de l'espace
nous les avons observés avec
émerveillement nous avons volé à travers
leur prennent et fugace un jour
peut-être nous toucherons ces messages
et d'un monde au delà des planètes